seguramente ya estás familiarizado con
la idea de la pendiente de una recta y
si no estás te encargo que pausas el
vídeo y vayas a repasar el concepto en
khan academy lo único que hace es
describir la tasa de cambio de una
variable vertical con respecto a una
variable horizontal así que por ejemplo
aquí tengo mi clásica james en el eje
vertical y mi clásica x en el eje
horizontal y si quisiera encontrar la
pendiente de esta recta podría elegir
dos puntos
digamos este punto y este punto y decir
ok de este punto a este punto cuál es mi
cambio en x bueno mi cambio en x va a
ser la distancia que tenemos aquí el
cambio en x este triángulo de aquí es la
letra griega delta mayúscula la cual es
un símbolo que representa el cambio así
que tengo el cambio en x y bueno también
puedo calcular cuánto es el cambio en
james es decir que si este punto sube
hasta este otro entonces tengo un cambio
que será éste
me cambio en yen y luego podemos definir
la pendiente como el cambio en james /
el cambio en x así que la pendiente va a
ser igual a la tasa de cambio de nuestro
eje vertical entre la tasa de cambio de
nuestro eje horizontal a veces lo
recordaremos como el desplazamiento
vertical entre el desplazamiento
horizontal y para cualquier recta
asociamos esto con la pendiente porque
cualquier recta tiene una tasa de cambio
constante si tomas cualquier par de
puntos de esta recta sin importar qué
tan lejos o qué tan cerca se encuentren
dondequiera que vivan en esta recta si
tú calculas la pendiente esta será la
misma y eso es lo que hace a una recta
ser una recta lo fascinante en el
cálculo es que vamos a construir las
herramientas para pensar en la tasa de
cambio no sólo de una recta antes
llamada pendiente sino pensar en la tasa
de cambio instantánea de una curva es
decir a una curva cuya tasa de cambio no
sea forzosamente constante así que por
ejemplo aquí tengo una
déjame hacerla donde la tasa de cambios
de con respecto a x cambia
constantemente pero si usamos nuestras
herramientas habituales y pensamos en la
tasa de cambio promedio entre estos dos
puntos digamos entre este punto y este
punto entonces primero pensemos en cuál
sería esa tasa de cambio bueno la tasa
de cambio promedio entre este punto y
este punto va a ser la pendiente de la
recta secante que conecta a estos dos
puntos entonces será la pendiente de
esta recta secante pero si tomamos otros
dos puntos distintos por ejemplo estos
otros dos la tasa de cambio promedio
entre esos dos puntos observa que va a
ser distinta parece que tiene una
pendiente mayor así que cuando tengamos
la pendiente de la recta secante entre
dos puntos de la curva puedes ver que
esa pendiente no siempre es la misma
para cualesquiera dos puntos
qué pasa si nos preguntamos algún poco
más interesante cuál va a ser la tasa de
cambio instantánea en un punto así que
por ejemplo qué tan rápido está
cambiando james con respecto a x en
exactamente este punto exactamente
cuando x toma este valor
llamémosle no sea x1 bueno la forma de
pensar la respuesta es trazar una recta
tangente en ese punto es decir una recta
que solo toque a este punto de la curva
y podemos calcular la pendiente de esta
recta tangente bueno esta será la tasa
de cambio instantánea en ese punto así
que en este caso la recta tangente se va
a ver así si sabemos la pendiente de
esta recta entonces podemos decir que
esa es la tasa de cambio instantánea
para ese punto y por qué digo
instantánea bueno piensa un poco en el
vídeo sobre usain bolt y los velocistas
si quieres saber la tasa de cambio de
usain bolt y lo piensas en un instante
dado bueno tal vez esto describa su
posición con respecto al tiempo y si que
fuera la posición 10 que fuera el tiempo
usualmente denotamos atp para el tiempo
pero imagina que en este caso es x
entonces si hablamos de lo que pasa en
este justo momento estaríamos hablando
de la tasa de cambio instantánea y esta
es la idea central del cálculo
diferencial que se le conoce con el
nombre de derivada la pendiente de la
recta tangente también la puedes llamar
la tasa de cambio instantánea
y estoy poniendo signos de exclamación
porque esto es muy importante así que
como denotamos una derivada bueno la
primera forma es usando lo que se conoce
como la anotación de leibovitz limits es
uno de los fundadores del cálculo junto
con isaac newton y la forma de denotar
lo es decir que la pendiente de la recta
tangente es igual
de james en tren de equis
ahora porque me gusta esta anotación
bueno porque esta viene directamente de
la noción de pendiente es decir de la
idea del cambio en james entre el cambio
en x y como verás en futuros vídeos una
forma de pensar en la pendiente de la
recta tangente es bueno calcular la
pendiente de la recta secante entre qué
tal este punto y este punto y después
acercarnos y calcular la pendiente de la
recta secante entre este punto y el que
buscamos y después acercarnos mucho más
y calcular la pendiente de la recta
secante entre este punto y el que
buscamos y ver qué es lo que pasa cuando
el cambio en x se aproxima a cero así
que cuando usas esta vez en lugar de
delta es la forma de leibniz de decir
hey
qué pasa sin mi cambio en x se acerca a
0 y bueno la anotación de learning se le
conoce como la anotación diferencial que
es fijarnos en un cambio en jr con
respecto a un cambio en x demasiado
pequeños un cambio en muy pequeño con
respecto a un cambio en x muy pequeño
especialmente cuando el cambio en x
pero como verás esta es la forma en la
que calculamos una derivada ahora
también hay otras notaciones por ejemplo
si esta curva la llevamos
james igual a fx entonces la pendiente
de la recta tangente la podemos denotar
como f prima del x1 en este caso esta es
la forma lagrange de denotar una
derivada y toma un poco de tiempo para
que la veas pero lo que dice
esencialmente es que f prima representa
la derivada lo que nos dice es que
tenemos la pendiente de la recta
tangente para un punto dado así que si
tú ingresas una equis en esta función
obtiene su correspondiente y pero si tú
ingreses una equis en f prima obtienes
la pendiente de la recta tangente en ese
punto
y por último otra anotación que aparece
menos en las clases de cálculo pero que
aparece más en las clases de física es
la anotación con un punto de punto que
también denota a la derivada también
puedes ver la anotación de 10 prima que
es un poco más común es clase de
matemáticas pero bueno es momento de
seguir nuestro paso en la aventura del
cálculo porque vamos a crear
herramientas para calcular estas
derivadas y si ya estás familiarizado
con los límites entonces te será muy
útil porque puedes pensar esto como el
límite del cambio en que con respecto a
x cuando el cambio en x se aproxima a 0
y no sólo vamos a averiguar esta
derivada para un solo punto vamos a
poder averiguar una ecuación que
describa la derivada para cualquier
punto de tu curva así que mantente muy
atento